c'est bon les preuves techniques sont
réglées
bien mes chers collègues
nous poursuivons les travaux de notre
mission d'information sur le
développement d'une filière de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert en accueillant
cet après-midi Monsieur Bruno even
directeur général on dit bien even
directeur
Eva
bon
directeur général d'Airbus hélicoptère
président du comité de pilotage du
conseil pour la recherche
aéronautique civil qui représente
aujourd'hui à la fois Airbus et le
groupement des industries françaises
aéronautique et spatial
monsieur even est accompagné par
plusieurs personnes que je salue
Monsieur Pierre Bourlot délégué général
du GIFAS
Monsieur Frédéric Parisot qui vient de
rejoindre le GIFAS après avoir été
majeur général de l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace que j'ai dû croiser sur la base
des mondes des Monts d'Or
monsieur Baptiste Voilquin directeur en
charge de la recherche développement et
de l'espace et de l'environnement
Monsieur Jérôme Jean directeur des
affaires publiques gif face et Madame
Anne-Sophie de Labigne
directrice des affaires civiles
françaises du groupe Airbus
je rappelle que cette réunion est captée
et diffusé en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat sur lequel elle pourra
ensuite être consulté en vidéo à la
demande monsieur le Président madame
messieurs notre mission d'information
comprend des membres issus des
différentes commissions et qui
représentent l'ensemble des groupes
politiques de notre assemblée le
développement des filières de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert sera l'un des
éléments importants de la décarbonation
des transports et donc l'une des voies
pour atteindre les objectifs ambitieux
que cet assigné l'Union européenne à
travers le pack vert et du paquet
ajustement de l'objectif 55
nous savons que le secteur aéronautique
présente des contraintes particulières
au regard des enjeux de décarbonation
les carburants d'aviation durables sont
ainsi au centre des attentions tant à
l'échange national qui a échelon
européen par ailleurs l'hydrogène en
tant que tel donne lieu à un certain
nombre de recherches et de projets
industriels en particulier chez Airbus
ces évolutions ne seront pas neutres ni
du point de vue industriel ni du point
de vue logistique pour les plateformes
aéroportuaires ni du point de vue du
coût d'approvisionnement au carburant
pour les compagnies aériennes la
question du prix de ces carburants est
un sujet de discussion avait entre les
compagnies aériennes et les producteurs
encore faut-il que ce fameux carburant
d'aviation durable soit disponible en
quantité suffisante là où les compagnies
en ont besoin
le gif face à piloté l'élaboration de la
feuille de route de décarbonation de
l'aérien publié le 18 avril dernier et
alimenter par les travaux du korak il
présente également le salon il prépare
pardon également le salon du Bourget qui
se tiendra dans quelques semaines ou le
gouvernement pourrait faire des annonces
il nous importe donc d'avoir votre
vision de ce dossier notre rapporteur
monsieur Vincent capo canelas qui est à
l'origine de notre mission vous a
adressé un questionnaire qui peut vous
servir guide mais monsieur even vous
introduisez votre propos comme vous
l'entendez je passerai ensuite la parole
à notre rapporteur puis à l'ensemble de
mes collègues afin qu'ils puissent vous
relancer et vous poser un certain nombre
de questions vous pourrez
ultérieurement nous transmettre des
réponses aux questions écrites qui vous
ont été adressées monsieur
even je vous souhaite la parole
merci beaucoup mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs sur le rapporteur de la
mission d'information merci pour cette
invitation qui comme vous l'avez
souligné dans votre introduction va nous
permettre d'échanger sur les défis
majeurs de l'industrie antique française
particulièrement le sujet de la
décarbonation et dans la décarbonation
évidemment les le sujet des nouveaux
carburants qui représente une part une
part déterminante donc nous avons
effectivement reçu les différentes
questions pour lesquelles un certain
nombre d'éléments de réponse vous ont
été transmis donc ce que ce que j'ai
prévu évidemment à propos liminaire qui
va reprendre et remettre en perspective
les principaux éléments de contexte et
les éléments qui nous sommes importants
de souligner évidemment nous sommes
disponibles également pour des
compléments de réponse premier élément
qui me semble important de souligner et
je voudrais commencer par ça c'est la
structuration de la filière aéronautique
française et je pense qu'il est
important d'avoir quelques chiffres en
tête pour pour souligner l'enjeu que
représente cette cette filière le jifa
c'est 444 membres
190 équipes entiers dont 38 start-up
221 et 221 PME c'est un chiffre
d'affaires global de plus de 62
milliards en 2022 + 13,6 % donc on voit
cette trajectoire de reprise post covid
dont plus de 40 milliards à
l'exportation avec des commandes à
hauteur de 65 milliards dont 75%
l'exportation donc on voit que ça soit
dans le chiffre d'affaires ou que ça
soit dans le le carnet de commandes
l'importance finalement de de
l'exportation et donc la contribution de
cette filière à la balance commerciale
française
on a tous en tête la crise du covid en
2020 qui a fortement pacté le tracker
aérien et donc il y a fortement impacté
cette filière donc après finalement
cette crise inédite 2021 2022 ont été
des années de des années de reprise et
de
qui ont confirmé la reprise de
l'industrie aéronautique si on regarde
en 2022 le trafic aérien au niveau
mondial est quasiment revenu au niveau
de 2019 alors pour autant et c'est aussi
important de l'avoir en tête on n'est
pas forcément nécessairement sorti de la
crise on est passé d'une crise de la
demande avec l'impact du covid à une
crise de l'offre dans un délai
particulièrement très court reprise très
forte de la demande et des enjeux de
industriels de monter en cadence de
l'ensemble de ce qu'on appelle la Supply
chaîne de l'ensemble des acteurs
industriels c'est le défi c'est le défi
d'aujourd'hui
et cette sortie de crise au-delà de la
supplation est marqué évidemment par une
économie mondiale qui a affectée par la
guerre en Ukraine et puis les enjeux de
d'énergie de matières premières
d'inflation et de ressources humaines de
compétences capacités à tirer et à
recruter
donc en 2023 la filière doit réussir ce
qu'on appelle le rang up donc la montée
en cadence pour tous les secteurs et
avec dans le même temps des
démonstrateurs de technologie nouvelles
qui sont essentielles au regard des
enjeux de compétitivité et des
carbonation donc c'est le contexte
global actuellement de la filière donc
le gif face et la filière poursuite sa
transformation avec des initiatives
telles que start r le club des startups
françaises de la filière créée en 2022
pour générer du lien et faire circuler
l'innovation entre start-up et
entreprise
au-delà de ce contexte crise crise de la
demande crise de l'offre maintenant avec
l'enjeu de montant cadence c'est ce que
vous avez souligné dans votre
introduction la filière de relever
plusieurs défis très importants et au
premier chef la décarbonation lorsqu'on
regarde l'histoire de l'aéronautique et
l'objectif de mon propos c'est
évidemment pas de faire un cours un
cours d'histoire mais c'est important de
mettre en perspective finalement avec la
décarbonation c'est la quatrième
révolution du transport aérien que nous
sommes en train de en train de vivre on
a eu le défi de la physique démontré que
ça pouvait voler on a eu le défi de la
sécurité le monde démontré qu'on pouvait
voler de manière sûre on a eu le défi de
la compétitivité démontrée qu'on pouvait
développer le vol commercial pour qu'il
soit accessible à tous et le quatrième
défi la quatrième révolution à laquelle
on fait face c'est démontré qu'on peut
voler de manière sûre de manière
compétitive et de manière décarbonée
pour illustrer l'enjeu de la filière le
transport aérien il est aujourd'hui
responsable de 2,5% des émissions de CO2
d'origine humaine mais il est important
d'avoir en tête que ce secteur aérien il
raisonne pas l'échelle nationale
hiraisonne évidemment c'est un secteur
aérien qui est mondial et important de
noter que l'ensemble des acteurs se sont
engagés en 2021 à atteindre l'objectif
ambitieux de 0 émission nette en 2000 en
2050 au niveau de l'ensemble des acteurs
industriels dans le centre de la filière
et dans le même temps les États membres
de l'OACI donc également au niveau
gouvernemental ce sont engagés en
travaillant ensemble sur le même
objectif lors de l'assemblée d'octobre
2022 donc il y a une vision commune un
engagement commun de l'ensemble des
acteurs ce qui est assez unique d'avoir
cette vision zéro émission nette en 2000
en 2050 donc c'est c'est un engagement
de la filière qui exemplaire au niveau
international mais également au niveau
au niveau français le secteur du
transport aérien a été ainsi le le
premier secteur à avoir remis
officiellement au gouvernement le 14
février 2023 sa feuille de route de
décarbonation au titre de l'article 301
de la loi climat et résilience on y
reviendra c'est évidemment un des accès
essentiels à travers la feuille de route
qui qui est qui est associée je tiens
souligner que l'élaboration a été
copiloté en 2022 avec la Direction
générale de l'aviation civile et le et
le gif face en lien avec les services de
l'État et à mobiliser finalement
l'ensemble des acteurs donc c'est
vraiment un travail un travail
collaboratif et coopératif je crois que
ça des réponds d'ailleurs à une de une
de vos questions le rapport de la
filière est désormais rendu public
conjointement par la flamme franc
hydrogène le GIFAS lui AF l'uefe et lui
fit em
le coracle vous l'avez souligné conseil
d'orientation pour la recherche
aéronautique civile donc j'ai la chance
d'occuper la présidence depuis
maintenant deux ans a également dans le
même temps publier ce qu'on appelle la
note de conviction pour un avion bas
carbone et un leadership de l'industrie
aéronautique française et cette note de
conviction et le résultat d'un travail
approfondi qui est mené maintenant
depuis près de trois ans dans le cadre
du plan de relance en 2020 c'est une
note de conviction à master plan
finalement de la filière qui a été
présenté dans ces grandes lignes et
chiffrées sur sur 10 ans la note de
conviction donc qui résume l'ensemble
des travaux fait depuis trois ans
rappelle qu'il s'agit sur la période
maintenant 2024 2029 de concrétiser les
efforts et les travaux de R&D en montant
maturité vers les phases de
démonstration et de créer les conditions
de lancement de programme donc on est
vraiment dans une dynamique le plan de
relance a créé à mobiliser l'ensemble
des acteurs autour d'enjeux de
décarbonation donc a permis d'élaborer
une feuille de route qui passe par une
première phase finalement 2020 2030 une
phase d'innovation de R&D de faisabilité
de démontrer que la technologie peut
être mature en vue dans ces des
programmes qui eux concrètement verront
l'entrée en service des avions
permettant d'assurer progressivement la
décarbonation
alors dans cette note de conviction dans
ce master plan on décrit les différents
leviers qui permettent d'atteindre cet
objectif de zéro mission à l'horizon en
2050 ces différents leviers il
s'additionnent ils sont complémentaires
et ils permettent de répondre à cet
enjeu donc le premier levier c'est le
renouvellement de des flottes des
flottes avions il s'agit de favoriser le
remplacement des avions les plus anciens
par des avions bénéficiants des
meilleurs performances sur le marché
si je prends l'exemple de l'intensité
carbone des missions des avions de la
gamme Airbus mesurée en quantité de CO2
émis par km et par passager elle a
diminué de 20% entre 2015 et 2022 donc
on voit très bien que l'innovation la
technologie permet de répondre
susceptible successivement à des enjeux
de réduction de CO2 évidemment il s'agit
ensuite de pouvoir favoriser le
renouvellement des avions puisque c'est
concrètement lorsque la technologie
rentre un service que les gains sont
mesurés seulement 20% seulement 20% de
la flotte actuellement en exploitation
est constituée des avions de dernière
génération donc on voit là qu'on a un
levier direct à travers la
renouvellement renouvellement des
flottes de pouvoir sur 80% apporté 15 à
20% de réduction de CO2
le second levier c'est de continuer en
parallèle sur l'innovation vers toujours
plus de performance et déficience pour
le développement d'appareil alors qu'on
appelle ultra frugaux ou zéro émission
alors les appareils
ultra frugaux alors c'est un terme qui
peut paraître barbare derrière la notion
de ultra fugale frugal évidemment peu de
consommation le ultra sous-entend que on
a une ambition supérieure à ce qu'on a
démontré dans le passé on voit que d'une
génération à l'autre en termes d'avions
on vise à gagner de quinze à 20% en
termes de consommation là l'objectif
c'est pour la première la prochaine
génération on veut aller gagner jusqu'à
30%. donc on veut accélérer et on veut
on veut multiplier l'effet de
performance par rapport à ce qu'on a
rencontré avec les générations
précédentes donc les appareils les
avions ultra frugaux ils intégreront des
moteurs à l'efficacité exacerbée via
l'augmentation de l'orthodilution avec
des moteurs plus larges voir sans
carénage dit open rotor et par
l'intégration d'un degré d'hybridation
électrique donc le premier levier les
moteurs le deuxième levier ils
embarqueront une avionique et des
systèmes plus électriques à Lyon basse
consommation et performances et
connectivité toujours améliorée un
troisième levier technologique c'est
également finalement une optimisation de
l'empreinte environnementale d'être
trajectoire minimisant la consommation
et les impacts climatiques donc toute
l'optimisation des trajectoires et puis
tout un axe d'innovation autour de
larchitecture avion pour atteindre des
performances aérodynamiques optimisées
on intégrant notamment des géométries
del variables pilotables ou des
revêtements aux propriétés
aérodynamiques qui limitent en
particulier à traîner de de frottement
donc un premier axe les avions ultra
frugaux et puis un deuxième axe
d'innovation pour la génération suivante
dans un calendrier dans un calendrier
ultérieur et c'est actuellement à
l'étude service pour mise en service à
l'horizon 2035 il fonctionne auront
quant à eux avec de l'hydrogène liquide
et nous mettrons donc aucun CO2 il
représente par un conséquent un atout
essentiel dans la décarbonation du
transport aérien mais leur introduction
sera progressive en fonction de
l'évolution des technologies et de la
montant puissance de l'écosystème à
social hydrogène en France et dans le
reste du monde l'enjeu en termes
d'innovation c'est de travailler dès à
présent sur les briques technologiques
qui adresseront ces deux défis mais sur
un terme calendaire si c'est essentiel
de démarrer dès maintenant sur ces deux
voies technologiques en termes de
calendrier ça va ça sera échelonné le le
premier enjeu c'est l'avion ultra frugal
qu'on voit en termes de lancement de
programme d'ici la fin de la décennie
d'ici 2030 et en parallèle par rapport à
la technologie hydrogène on voit une
introduction non pas directement sur les
avions dit mono couloir type successeur
de la 320 on le voit sur des avions
plutôt régionaux pour non seulement
valider les technologies mais également
construire l'ensemble de l'écosystème
puisque c'est ce que je mentionnais à
l'instant un des défis d'hydrogène c'est
pas uniquement la technologie embarquée
qui permet d'avoir une capacité de
propulsion hydrogène c'est également
l'ensemble de l'écosystème y compris
évidemment la chaîne d'approvisionnement
et de transport au sol
donc le troisième levier le premier
renouvellement le deuxième l'innovation
avec ces deux axes apparaît ultra
frugaux et avions zéro émission le
troisième levier et l'utilisation de
carburant aéronautique durable qui ont
l'avantage de pouvoir utiliser sur les
avions existants puisque j'y reviendrai
je pense par la suite mais les avions
les moteurs sont déjà certifiés
aujourd'hui pour des mélanges de l'ordre
de 50% donc ils ont l'avantage de
pouvoir utiliser sur les avions
existants tout en pouvant réduire les
émissions de CO2 de plus de 80% sur un
cycle complet
l'ensemble des seuls leviers sont
additionnels il s'additionnent ils sont
aussi complémentaires on y reviendra par
la suite mais le sujet des carburants
déviation durable en dehors de de
l'enjeu de créer la filière il y aura un
enjeu de de coûts avec des coûts qu'on
estime entre un facteur 2 à 3 par
rapport au kérosène donc on voit bien
que dans le même temps travailler sur
des technologies qui permettent de
réduire la consommation est un élément
clé par rapport au développement des
carburants d'aviation durable donc
j'insiste sur le fait que l'ensemble des
seuls leviers sont comp
un point peut-être rapide sur la
définition et la nature des carburants
d'aviation durable ce sont des liquides
constitués d'une composition de
molécules similaire à celle du kérosène
fossile donc des chaînes carbonées C10
ac14 même propriété physique point de
congélation notamment mais sans contenu
en carbone d'origine fossile tous
utilise une certaine quantité
d'hydrogène mélangez à une source de
carbone qui peut être d'origine
biologique se trouvait dans des chaises
organiques ou industriels ou encore
directement prélevé dans l'air la
capture de carbone cette filière sont
certifiées jusqu'à un taux
d'incorporation de 50%
dont 4 en particulier sont considérés
comme devant avoir une contribution
forte à la demande en volume à l'horizon
2030 alors il y a ce qu'on appelle les
efforts hefa oui les graisses hydroté
produit à partir de matières premières
en relation la plus technique de l'axe 9
de la directive européenne red sur les
énergies renouvelables donc oui les
graisses recyclées le BTL
obtenu par le procédé de gaz et
efficacion et recomposition fishertrop à
partir de biomasse solide de type
résidus agricoles résidus forestier
plantes l’hypnose etulosique ou des
chaises municipaux troisième filière
c'est le procédé alcool to jet ATI qui
lui utilise un processus chimique pour
la conversion de biomasse lino
cellulosique et le quatrième CP pitiel
power to liquide ou ifuel qui est un
carburant purement synthétique produit à
partir des rejets de CO2 capturé
directement dans l'air et fluant ou
atmosphère qui ne dépend donc pas de la
biomasse mais demande de plus grandes
quantités d'électricité tous ces
carburants devront être conformes au
règlement review et à la directive red
européen qui garantissent leur
durabilité qui ne rentre pas en
concurrence donc avec la nourriture
humaine ou animale leur birl en carbone
devrait être supérieur à 70%, ce qui
signifie que le carbone capté par la
photosynthèse ou par la captation des
gaz dans l'atmosphère devra être
supérieure de 70% à celui am pour leur
production et pendant le vol donc après
ces éléments rapides de définition et
d'introduction en jeu pour le
déploiement de l'utilisation des
carburants déviation durables donc les
travaux pour atteindre la certification
à hauteur de 100%, puisque j'ai souligné
qu'ils étaient aujourd'hui des avions et
moteurs certifiés à 50% sont en cours
notamment via la feuille de route du
Corac elle va être entre autres les
premières démonstrations en vol
d'hélicoptère et d'aéronef commerciaux
utilisant des carburants d'aviation
durable pur c'est le projet qui est mené
conjointement avec des DGAC le projet
qu'on appelle volcan les enjeux
concernent en particulier la
compatibilité de certains matériaux et
la stomèrent notamment sur certaines
fonctions telles que les joints ou les
tuyauteries l'objectif c'est d'être
capable de démontrer cette capacité 100%
l'horizon 2025 2026 le second point clé
c'est l'augmentation des volumes de
production de carburant d'aviation
durable donc toute la chaîne de
production à la chaîne logistique les
scénarios SNBC article 30 décrivent
d'ici 2050 un besoin en carburant
d'aviation durable de l'ordre de 7 à 8
mégatonnes par an biofioul seifuel
représentant un besoin estimé en
biomasse de l'ordre de 12 avec 14 tonnes
par an plus 100 terawattheure
d'électricité des carbonées évidemment
tout l'enjeu par rapport à l'électricité
qui soit qui sera utilisé c'est qu'elle
soit décarbonée et là de ce point de vue
là au niveau national on a on a un
positionnement assez spécifique et
qui peut être exploité l'introduction de
tel volume appelle également une
amélioration des procédés ou le
développement de nouvelles technologies
de conversion offrant des rendements et
des performances économiques supérieures
ces nouvelles filières donc de
production devront être certifiés au
niveau international avec une recherche
d'efficacité accrue du processus à ce
titre une structuration des acteurs
français européens et nécessaires afin
de soutenir le projet de Clearinghouse
porté par les ASA c'est-à-dire de
guichet unique permettant aux candidat à
la certification de trouver un soutien
technique administratif et financier
donc tout l'aspect évidemment normatif
réglementaire est essentiel par rapport
au développement de cette filière là
au delà des enjeux les scénarios
travaillés trois scénarios
d'introduction des carburants en
aviation durables ont été définies le
premier qui vise 6% d'un coopération en
2030 et 63% en 2050 selon le projet
initial de la Commission européenne et
fait un très large appel au biocarburant
près de 33%, le power to liquide PTL
représentant 27% et hydrogène 5% pour
tous les départs France internationaux
le deuxième scénario vise quant à lui
10% d'incorporation en 2030 et non plus
6% et 85% de 2050 il fait il fait appel
à plus d'électrocarburant donc cette
fois-ci c'est 44% de PTL contrairement
au scénario précédent qui est à 27%, et
l'hydrogène également qui monte de 5 à
12% avec une accélération de
l'introduction des avions hydrogène ce
scénario correspond à un recours plus
limité à la biomasse mais demande plus
d'électricité donc c'est évidemment le
compromis et le trader
à noter que l'accord politique obtenu à
Bruxelles sur le review prévoit quant à
lui finalement 6% de carburant
d'affiliation durable en 2030 et 70% de
2050 dont 35% de pitié donc on voit que
le avec le premier scénario on est on
est dans les ordres de grandeur on a un
troisième scénario évidemment plus
ambitieux qui est une variante du
présent avec le même objectif de 85 % de
carburant aviation durable en 2050 mais
cette fois avec plus de biomasse en
utilisant le procédé hybride ibitiel qui
consiste à injecter dans le processus
BTL on commence à rentrer dans les dans
les sigles de l'hydrogène à partir
d'électrolyse ce qui permet de mieux
utiliser le carbone contenu dans la
biomasse et d'augmenter ainsi les
rendements dans ce cas la biomias
redevient majoritaire avec 50% dont 35%
des Bitcoin le power to liquide étant
étant à lui à 25% hydrogène à 12%. ceci
permet aussi de faire baisser la demande
en électricité d'environ 10 terawatters
les carburants aéronautiques durable
sont donc bien une composante majeure de
la décarbonation du transport aérien
quel que soit le scénario les acteurs de
la construction aéronautique sont
engagés à jouer leur rôle dans
l'émergence des renettes compatible à
100%, c'est le projet Vulcain que je
mentionnais avec l'objectif de le
démontrer à l'horizon 2025 2026 et a pu
la démarche d'émergence d'une filière de
production et de distribution des
carburants aéronautiques durables
sachant que l'enjeu va donc résider dans
les quantités de matières premières
disponibles et de puissance électrique
qui sera nécessaire pour le processus en
ce sens la récente mise en place du
groupe travail de haut niveau
rassemblant l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés est un signal fort pouvoir
émerger les incitations politiques et le
cadre réglementaire nécessaire
avant de conclure ce propos liminaire
évidemment disponible pour toutes les
questions je souhaiterais mais je
comprends que vous l'aviez abordé
également aborder le thème du Salon
international de l'aéronautique de
l'espace au Bourget ça va être
évidemment un rendez-vous important pour
pour la profession du 19 au 25 juin avec
des rendez-vous importants par icerlab
un focus évidemment sur l'enjeu de la
décarbonation et sur l'enjeu des des
initiatives en termes d'innovation
l'avion des métiers je l'ai souligné en
introduction c'est aujourd'hui dans la
montée en cadence l'un des plus grands
défis de la filière la capacité à
attirer les talents et les et les
compétences Paris remobility une
opération start-up Start me up
l'opération l'aéron recrute journée
grand public donné de la visibilité et
puis évidemment une grande fête aérienne
tout le tous les week-ends
bicarbonation du transport aérien
l'exposition à vocation internationale
s'appuiera sur la contribution d'une
trentaine d'acteurs sous la forme de
maquette support visuel et interactif
pour aborder les thèmes majeurs suivants
et je peux exhaustif mais évidemment les
carburants alternatifs durables en font
partie il y aura évidemment aussi des
plantations autour des thématiques de
l'hydrogène de l'avion plus électrique
des moteurs ultrasobres de choix
d'architecture de voilure innovantes et
je m'arrête là mais évidemment tout un
choix et un panel de de technologie il y
aura également des conférences tout
autour de cette thème là tout au long de
la semaine donc évidemment si j'en parle
c'est que nous sommes très heureux de
pouvoir vous y accueillir dans
maintenant près de un peu plus de deux
semaines je vous remercie pour votre
attention évidemment nous sommes
disponibles pour vos questions merci
Monsieur Emmanuel monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président even d'abord merci
de cette présentation
plusieurs plusieurs questions
d'abord vous avez rappelé le scénario en
tout cas l'objectif
zéro émission nette en 2050 objectif
de l'OACI
comment vous voyez la capacité
des différents pays des différents
continents à
converger de manière
relativement coordonnée et à permettre
que
les compagnies ne soient pas
soumises à une concurrence qui viendrait
notamment des pays qui sont pas dans
l'Union européenne avec des objectifs
d'incorporation différent et donc des
coûts différents
est-ce que vous vous soutenez des
démarches diplomatiques à l'OACI
démarche sur les accords de réciprocité
qui permettront dans ce cas là
de faire que
noob ne soit pas pénalisé
et que les lignes d'ailleurs
qui sont opérés par les compagnies de
l'Union européenne ne se retrouvent pas
soumises à une très forte concurrence de
pays qui n'auraient pas les mêmes coûts
si vous avez rappelé que derrière
les biocarburants ou les fuels derrière
et il y a un coût qui est évidemment
supérieur
ça c'est le premier sujet et puis je
voulais également vous poser des
questions puisque vous êtes
en présentant du gif face mais aussi au
travers d'abus hélicoptères et du groupe
airbuses représentant d'un groupe qui
est leader au niveau mondial vous avez
forcément des clients dans le monde
entier vous avez des relations au niveau
militaire avec toutes les tous les états
grand nombre c'est heureux c'est une
très très belle entreprise qui fait
notre fierté mais quand vous regardez la
façon que les pays ont d'appréhender
cette décarbonation
et que vous nous comparez
quelles leçons vous en tirer est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que nous nous
sommes mis collectivement au niveau
français européen dans une stratégie qui
vous paraît efficace soutenable qui
préserve aussi l'emploi la souveraineté
est-ce que tout le dispositif
d'accompagnement vous paraît suffisant
votre regard international nous nous
importe beaucoup sachant que cette
mission elle vise à regarder
comment la filière de biocarburant de
carburant synthétique et l'hydrogène
peut
soutenir la décarbonation du transport
aérien c'est ça la démarche et donc nous
on est soucieux d'avoir votre regard sur
ces éléments de comparaison
puis deux questions peut-être plus
ponctuelles sur la certification
vous nous avez rappelé que aujourd'hui
le seuil est à 100% d'incorporation
pardon 50% d'incorporation et qu'on va
viser les 100% alors
on entend parfois vous avez rappelé les
sujets sur
la tuyauterie sur les joints etc bon
entrer dans la technique mais est-ce que
vous vous dites aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de sujet que les ingénieurs ne sachent
régler on l'a entendu
et confiance on y va où est-ce que vous
nous dites quand même on est malgré tout
scientifique et on attend d'y voir clair
mais est-ce que est-ce que ce seuil là
des 50% peut être levé facilement vous
allez dire je suis bien compris 25-26
fin 2025 et 26
contact mais
ça ça vous paraît finalement un horizon
qu'on peut dépasser rapidement ou pas et
puis surtout
sur le besoin parce qu'après la question
c'est comment on produit et on entend
bien
le la démarche biocarburant et puis
jusqu'au ifuel pour faire vite je vais
pas tout résumer
vous nous dites un besoin 7 à 8 millions
de tonnes alors est-ce que c'est un
chiffre enfin je pense c'était un excès
de les besoins de la France là c'est
vraiment c'est sans doute
toute l'Union européenne mais même là
j'ai un peu le sentiment que c'est ça va
ça va relativement vite en tout cas à
quelle horizon vous êtes est-ce que vous
êtes à 2050
pour situer millions tonnes parce que
nous on a chiffrage qui est en gros de 3
à 4 millions de tonnes nécessaires en
2030 pour l'Union européenne et le
Royaume-Uni le tout le tout réuni et
pour faire vite de grandeur mais vous
pourrez l'affiner ou le ou le contester
on a plutôt à l'esprit qu'aujourd'hui on
se mettra en situation mais c'est à
vérifier de produire 2 millions donc on
a quand même un vrai sujet qui intéresse
les
producteurs de carburant
les énergéticiens comme on dit qui est
de savoir comment on va passer de une
capacité de 1030 théorique de millions
tonnes à alors soit 3 à 4 pour 2030
comme besoin nécessaire est-ce que on va
Air France d'ailleurs courageusement le
dit
pas la pierre mais j'ai encore entendu
ce matin à la radio des déclarations
d'Adrien qui est venue devant notre
mission et qui a tenu à propos tout à
fait responsable et sérieux et
volontariste mais Adrien ne nous dit
finalement j'ai plus de facilité à me
fournir aux USA ou
dans chez certaines entreprises on va on
va citer nester que de me fournir en
français donc comment vous voyez ça
parce qu'il me semble que pour la
filière c'est quand même le sujet majeur
comment on décarbonne et tout le reste
est quand même un tout petit peu
fragilisé si on répond pas à cette
partie là donc j'imagine que en tant
qu'industriel le représentant industriel
de GIFAS vous avez un point de vue sur
le sujet
donc nous nous sommes attentifs à toute
mesure de structuration de la filière
que vous pourriez avoir à l'esprit comme
étant une éventualité à regarder voilà
sur quelques premiers points on vous
remercie
quelques éléments de réponse et
n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas évidemment à
compléter je vais démarrer par le
deuxième volet de la question puis je
reviendrai évidemment sur le premier là
autour des carburants déviation durable
le premier le premier volet de la
question
avion moteur certifié à 50%, il y a une
feuille de route à 100%
qui suppose évidemment
une démonstration technologique donc
avec une part de niveau de confiance et
quelque part la question c'est quel
niveau de confiance qu'on a sur le fait
qu'on va pouvoir atteindre 100% et donc
du coup on y va on y va pas sur le sujet
des carburants
le premier élément à avoir en tête c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on est à zéro quasiment
quasiment zéro d'incorporation donc
indépendamment de la démonstration du
fait qu'on puisse passer de 50% à 100%
dès lors qu'on a aujourd'hui les avions
moteurs qui sont certifiés à 50% le
potentiel il est là et on voit que c'est
un ordre 1 dans la trajectoire de
décarbonation donc dans mon esprit il y
a pas de il y a pas de débat
indépendamment de la démonstration
technologique qu'on peut étendre jusqu'à
100% et qu'on pourra certifier des
technologies à 100% de car durable il ne
faut pas attendre je pense qu'on a trop
attendu il faut il faut y aller dès à
présent c'est pas un débat de
technologie la technologie est capable
c'est un débat d'écosystème c'est un
débat de chaîne de production de
logistique avec le fameux le fameux
finalement syndrome de la poule et de
l'oeuf c'est à dire que oui il y a un
débat de compétitivité c'est-à-dire il y
a un coût du carburant d'aviation
durable qui est bien plus important que
le kérosène dans un monde qui est
compétitif aujourd'hui s'il y a pas une
structuration s'il y a pas des
mécanismes finalement incitatifs on va
pas amorcer la pompe et c'est le fait
d'amorcer la pompe et donc d'amorcer la
demande qui va générer le volume et qui
va du coup générer la réduction des
coûts qui va rendre ce carburant de la
visation durable attractif donc il y a
ce débat de la technologie passer de 50%
100% je parlais du projet Vulcain il est
déjà sec il y a pas de doute il y a des
sujets techniques à aborder vous les
avez mentionnés l'idée c'est pas de
faire de la technique ici mais mais il y
a pas de doute sur le sur le fait qu'à
l'horizon 2025 2026 on saura démontré le
100% le message le message très fort
c'est n'attend pas n'attendons pas
2025-2026 pour lancer les initiatives
mettre en place les actions qui
permettent le développement des
carburants d'aviation durable l'ambition
dans les différents scénarios et compris
celui validé au niveau du européenne je
rappelle qu'à l'horizon 2030 on est sur
sur 6% donc on est de toute façon dans
le seuil de certification des des 50% ça
me semble important de 120% de la voir
de l'avoir de l'avoir en tête
ensuite le c'est finalement le cœur du
sujet votre la deuxième volet de votre
question autour des carburants de
navigation durables le sujet de
l'écosystème le sujet de la chaîne de la
chaîne de production
vous me corrigez à ma droite ou à ma
gauche mais Lady méga tonnes par an
c'est à horizon 2050 donc c'est dans une
vision développement des carburants
d'aviation durables à l'horizon 2050
c'est le besoin qu'on estime en termes
de consommation par rapport au trafic
aérien donc j'ai peut-être par rapport
aux chiffres que vous aviez ou on est
sur des horizons de temps peut-être
qu'ils sont différents et là vous êtes
sur quel périmètre là
c'est France domestique plus France
départ international en 2050 en 2050
pendant 2 secondes mais je reviens juste
sur la certification pour vous dire les
choses clairement on a entendu les
autorités qui se gouvertification qui
nous ont dit a priori tout le monde nous
dit que c'est pas compliqué de passer le
seuil de 50% mais il faut quand même
qu'on nous le prouve
celui qui va signer en bas de la feuille
pendant une pendant la responsabilité et
ça ne sera pas que que les autorités
françaises d'ailleurs sans doute mais
je voudrais quand même on est bien
d'accord c'est à dire que la
certification elle n'est prononcée que
lorsque l'ensemble du dossier technique
est validé et compris l'ensemble des
tests des démonstrations donc c'est à la
fin du process est-ce qu'on voit 2025
l'ensemble des acteurs sont confiants il
faut qu'on exécute d'où les projets qui
sont lancés mon point c'est de souligner
en parallèle de cette démonstration sur
lesquelles il y a un niveau de confiance
raisonnable encore faut-il aller jusqu'à
évidemment la démonstration
on a aujourd'hui un niveau de
certification à son compte pour ça qui
justifie d'ores et déjà par rapport au
potentiel de s'engager dans le
développement de cette filière et ne
serait-ce que l'objectif 2030 par
rapport à 6%
donc
l'enjeu il est bien évidemment au niveau
de la chaîne de production au niveau de
l'écho l'écosystème production
approvisionnement d'avoir les points
d'approvisionnement c'est l'ensemble
finalement de de l'écosystème en
incluant les aéroports les compagnies
aériennes évidemment les les
acteurs les acteurs et les avionneurs
c'est l'ensemble de cette écosystème qui
doit se mettre se mettre en route par
rapport à cet objectif 2030 qui passe
qui est déjà à 6% et là c'est un débat
de norme ça ne va régulative mais c'est
également un débat d'un site incitatif
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut effectivement et
c'est là où on voit un certain temps de
d'actions qui sont menées des groupes de
travail qui mobilisent l'ensemble des
acteurs c'était essentiel c'est
essentiel puisque quelque part pour
engager l'ensemble des acteurs sur un
une solution qui au départ sera vu comme
étant plus cher que le raisin classique
un moment donné il faut bien ces mesures
incitatives donc c'est un élément
essentiel pour rentrer dans cette boucle
vertueuse qui fera que les producteurs
seront intéressés il y aura une demande
il y aura du volume et sa réduira et sa
réduira le coût de le coût du production
et donc ça ça développera la demande je
l'ai mentionné dans mon introduction
c'est vraiment complémentaire du travail
en même temps sur la technologie de
réduction de la consommation puisque en
vision en vision moyen terme on
considère néanmoins même dans une
logique de développement que le coût de
production restera supérieur à celui des
kérosène donc c'est un des paramètres
d'ailleurs qu'on intègre dans nos
modèles par rapport à la croissance du
trafic aérien on intègre le fait que il
y aura un coût du carburant plus plus
élevé mais d'où l'enjeu de travailler
également sur des solutions dit ultra
frugal qui permettent de réduire la
consommation et donc le coût global des
carburants donc j'ai bien noté la
remarque de Rigail et je pense que c'est
un élément essentiel qu'au niveau
national européen évidemment on crée le
contexte réglementaire normatif
incitatif fiscal pour mobiliser
mobiliser la filière autour de du
développement des carburant d'aviation
durables les solutions les solutants
technologiques elles existent il y a un
certain nombre de de filières par
rapport aux parents c'est pas 100% de
biomasse c'est un mixte on l'a vu entre
les différents scénarios y compris les
carburants les carburants synthétiques
donc tout ne sera pas adressé à travers
la biomasse la biomasse donc c'est
l'enjeu à la fois finalement
d'électricité et puis et puis de
disponibilité des biofuels sur la
première partie de la de la de la
question par rapport finalement level
play field et finalement l'enjeu de
rester sur un terrain de jeu je dirais
un marché
faire équilibrer en termes de
compétitivité et qu'on ne crée pas une
distorsion une distorsion de concurrence
avec finalement des exigences
réglementaires qui seraient différentes
en France et en Europe par rapport au
reste du monde évidemment une question
qui est fondamentale le premier point
par rapport à l'ambition 0 émission 2050
vous avez mentionné l'OACI je
mentionnerai que c'est il y a l'aspect
je dirais des gouvernements l'aspect
étatique il y a aussi l'aspect les
acteurs industriels donc c'est vraiment
l'ensemble des acteurs qui sont engagés
sur cet objectif là à la fois les
acteurs industriels et puis à la fois à
travers l'OACI évidemment les les
différents pays représentatifs c'est
essentiel de garder cette dynamique
internationale au regard de la question
que vous vous soulevez donc je par
rapport à la question est-ce qu'on
soutient toutes les actions au niveau
diplomatique pour s'assurer de la
réciprocité c'est essentiel ça sera ça
sera essentiel pour s'assurer que on n'a
pas on n'a pas des exigences au niveau
national au niveau européen qui serait
décorrélés des exigences qui pourraient
y avoir dans d'autres dans d'autres pays
ou d'autres régions du monde il y a le
risque que vous mentionnez par rapport
finalement à des compagnies qui
compagnie aériennes qui feraient l'objet
qui ferait l'objet d'une d'une
concurrence sur d'autres lignes qui ne
seraient pas soumises au même au même au
même condition au niveau de l'Europe ou
aux portes de l'Europe c'est vrai pour
les constructeurs aussi ça dans une
logique ou par rapport à cette ambition
à laquelle on croit en termes de
constructeur on s'engageant sur des
solutions technologiques et donc des
avions qui répondent à cet enjeu de
décarbonation si à un moment donné cette
technologie qui répondent à un enjeu
souligné par nos autorités si ce besoin
là n'est pas souligné dans d'autres
parties du monde évidemment on va se
retrouver avec le logis et des avions
potentiellement plus cher par rapport à
un enjeu et c'est tout à fait justifié
et on est engagé dans cette voie là mais
il faudrait pas se retrouver
effectivement dans une situation où on a
des solutions qui ne seraient pas
compétitives par rapport au reste du
monde donc à la fois l'ambition elle est
elle est incontournable l'enjeu de la
décarbonation du trafic aérien
nous y sommes engagés au niveau de la au
niveau de la filière c'est l'ensemble
des acteurs au niveau au niveau mondial
qui sont qui sont engagés il est
essentiel de garder toutes ces actions
au niveau diplomatique pour garder la
cohérence de l'exigence et la cohérence
du cadre du cadre réglementaire c'est
enfin le point que vous soulignez dans
votre question est au cœur est au cœur
évidemment de la de la démarche
oui merci sur le la partie qui concerne
justement la filière
de de carburant de carburant synthétique
là
où est-ce que vous en êtes ton dialogue
j'imagine que vous l'avez comme les
compagnies peuvent la voir mais vous
avec une vision peut-être plus
prospective
avec les énergéticiens puisque la
question c'est aujourd'hui comment on
crée un marché et comment on arrive à
satisfaire une demande que les
compagnies expriment
jusqu'au 50% et
comment on arrive à faire que le secteur
aérien montre qu'il est en voie de ce
décarbonée de manière rapide puisque
l'opinion
entre guillemets a décroché
et
regarde le secteur aérien
stigmatisant et on voit encore la
semaine dernière une annonce de taxation
de plus pour le secteur donc pardon de
lui poser en terme un peu brutal mais tu
es un brutaux pardon mais
je me dis que tout à l'heure vous disiez
un peu le fait la poule c'est vrai
mais on a le sentiment que cette affaire
n'est pas réglé le niveau de production
et le niveau de prix alors vous allez me
dire c'est pas vous c'est le
gouvernement c'est à nous de faire des
propositions mais justement si on a si
j'ai suggéré avec le groupe
innocentrisme de créer cette cette
mission et c'est mes collègues avec moi
essaye de travailler là-dessus c'est
dans l'idée de d'essayer de faire
émerger ce marché notamment bon ça c'est
un premier sujet et puis juste après je
vais passer l'appareil à mes collègues
sur l'hydrogène
et l'affaire de l'avion électrique parce
que il y a 18 mois on se serait vu on se
serait dit tiens
il y a eu des annonces gouvernementales
et on nous a dit 2035 l'hydrogène
alors maintenant on nous dit oui
je vais pas dire prototype enfin bon de
mes 35 il y aura sans doute quelques
avions à hydrogène mais enfin pour voir
comment ça marche bon
on peut on a plutôt entendu que c'était
plutôt réaliste c'est-à-dire de dire
pour le moment biocarburant carburant
synthétique ok une bonne part de la
monnaie
mais où est-ce que vous en êtes et puis
au titre d'Airbus aussi
sur l'hydrogène on a plutôt compris que
c'était courrier
moyen courrier mais qui est quand même
une rupture technologique et qui a tout
un sujet d'environnement autour
notamment sur les aéroports et puis
alors pour le coup
il s'agit pas de partir d'Europe et
d'atterrir ailleurs sans qu'il y ait
aussi les mêmes infrastructures donc sur
hydrogène ou est-ce que vous en êtes de
la technologie de de la réflexion
idem sur la partie alors il y aura au
Bourget je crois un avion
dit Héra qui va être ni bride alors
pardon c'est pas
Airbus mais je pense qu'il est adhérent
du GIFAS
ou sinon faudra lui conseiller de
voilà c'est au héros
il est chez vous bon très bien bon mais
ça c'est une innovation c'est à dire
qu'avion hybride avec
un dispositif électrique si j'ai bien
compris au décollage à l'atterrissage
c'est quand même très bien pour les
riverains bon alors c'est un module je
suis bien compris 19 places curiosité
d'aller le voir
peut-être qu'on ira le voir ensemble
mais bon donc suédogène et sur
électrique ou est-ce que vous en êtes et
puis dernier point le coracle alors
peut-être que vous êtes président du
corail nous rappeler moi ce que je
comprends c'est une structure qui
rassemble les pouvoirs publics les
industriels le monde de la recherche
pour fixer des feuilles de route et
essayer de voir comment on converge pour
mener cette recherche de manière
opérationnelle mais
j'ai en tête
de la commission des finances que le
financement du coracle n'est pas assuré
et qu'il y a quand même des points
d'alerte alors peut-être pas
cette année mais assez vite derrière
donc voilà merci vous pouvez aborder ce
point aussi
s'il vous plaît
on est suivi
de points
juste pour revenir par rapport à la
série de questions précédentes avant de
revenir sur sur les questions que vous
avez soulevées ici on parlait à un
moment donné du caractère finalement
incitatif on faisait référence aux
États-Unis effectivement en gardant en
tête les mécanismes qui ont été mis en
place aux États-Unis à travers
l'IAE qui est vraiment est un phénomène
incitatif de soutien l'ensemble des
initiatives qui visent à le
décarbonation donc on me fait le
parallèle à nos enjeux de développement
des filières à carburation durable c'est
évidemment un enjeu essentiel que d'être
capable d'avoir des soutiens similaires
pour garder finalement une concurrence
une concurrence équitable ça me semble
être un élément un élément essentiel
vous avez souligné également
dans un des volets de la question
l'aspect finalement l'image du transport
du transport aérien je voudrais
souligner plusieurs plusieurs éléments
le premier élément c'est le transport
aérien est engagé et je souligne qu'on
est le premier secteur un des premières
secteurs industriels à avoir remis une
feuille de route dans le cadre de l'arc
T3 101 par rapport à des carbonation
donc on est une filière engagée avec une
feuille de route crédible solide qui
vise à l'horizon 2050 à avoir une
industrie décarbonée à travers les
différents leviers qu'on a utilisé j'y
reviendrai sur l'aspect Correc
financement mais c'est le premier
élément qui me semble essentiel il y a
un engagement il y a une feuille de
route crédible deuxième élément c'est
évidemment le transport aérien il y a le
défi de la décarbonation sur lequel nous
avons cette feuille de route il ne faut
pas mettre de côté l'ensemble de la
contribution du trafic du secteur aérien
à la fois à l'économie nationale à
l'économie européenne internationale
c'est une filière d'excellence premier
contributeur à la à la balance
commerciale et c'est également on peut
raisonner à l'échelle nationale mais si
on regarde à l'échelle européenne pour
internationale on a aussi un certain
nombre de régions du monde sur
lesquelles l'aérien et bien souvent la
seule source ou moyen de décloisonnement
donc ça contribue évidemment à un monde
non seulement en développement mais un
monde un monde comme on dit soutenable
ou
l'ensemble des acteurs sont connectés
donc lorsqu'on regarde le secteur aérien
il faut regarder son défi de la
décarbonation mais également tout ce
qu'il a apporté tout ce qui continue
d'apporter ça me semble semblant
essentiel par rapport au sujet des
carburants aviation durables où on en
est il y a le groupe de travail de haut
niveau qui a été créé sous l'impulsion
ministériel transition énergétique
industrie transport il a été créé le 14
février donc un centre de groupes de
travail qui ont été et qui ont été
initiés qui regroupent l'ensemble des
acteurs et donc y compris les énergétic
donc on peut se dire effectivement
mi-février on aurait pu le faire avant
il est là et soit je pense que c'est une
bonne chose la dynamique est en place
avec une dimension transversale
l'ensemble de l'écosystème immobilisé et
on verra au niveau du Bourget des
communications par rapport à un certain
nombre de résultats donc
par rapport à ce défi de mobiliser
l'ensemble de l'écosystème je pense que
le système est en marche système
timbranle en appliquant l'ensemble des
acteurs donc de ce point de vue là de ce
point de vue là je suis assez positif
maintenant il faut évidemment aller
jusqu'au bout et obtenir et démontrer et
démontrer que que la filière la filière
se développe par rapport à l'hydrogène
où on en est
important d'avoir en tête le fait qu'on
travaille dans le cadre de la feuille de
route Cora qui vise à la décarbonation
du secteur arrière sur plusieurs
filières technologiques en parallèle
l'ultra frugalité et donc là on
travaille sur des technologies moteur
avion qui vise à être capable de lancer
un programme successeur
monocouloire type A320 à l'horizon à
l'horizon 2030 on est sur une
accélération en termes de performance
par rapport à ce qu'on est dans le passé
mais on est dans cette on est dans cette
logique là la technologie hydrogène
permet de couper parce que il pourra
utiliser une masse d'hydrogène parce que
l'avion il nous convient à 40 ans on est
donc c'est un avion
on est typiquement sur sur une
quarantaine d'années par rapport aux
générations les nouveaux moteurs ils
pourront pas utiliser l'hydrogène de
main on voit bien sur la on prend des
hypothèses non mais c'est une bonne
remarque je mentionnais tout à l'heure
le fait que quand on regarde les avions
qui sont actuellement en service il y en
a 20% qui sont nouvelle génération
c'est-à-dire c'est déjà le cas il y a
80% aujourd'hui qui sont de génération
précédente donc on va voir le même le
même phénomène par rapport aux nouvelles
technologies on a les avions
d'aujourd'hui on aura les avions ultra
frugaux dans les programmes seront
lancés à l'horizon 2030 les avions
hydrogène et donc il y aura
effectivement des systèmes de
séquencement ou plusieurs technologies
pourront exister en parallèle mon point
c'est dire sur l'hydrogène on a un enjeu
dans le cadre de la feuille de route
korak à travers des démonstrations sols
à travers des démonstrations vols sur
certains éléments de ce système ou sur
l'architecture complète puisqu'on parle
ici finalement de d'être capable de
consommer de l'hydrogène donc qui sera
liquide à bord par rapport à la
problématique de densité volumique de
l'hydrogène donc d'être capable de
consommer d'hydrogène à bord par rapport
à des technologies des théologies
moteurs donc on est on est sur un
démontrer la capacité de transport la
capacité de stockage par rapport à un
carburant inflammable donc on a
l'ensemble des démonstrations à faire au
niveau des briques technologiques et au
niveau de l'architecture et donc cette
feuille de route Cora glisse d'ici le
2030 à être capable de démontrer
l'ensemble des briques technologiques
pour être capable de lancer un nouveau
programme dit avion à hydrogène qu'on
envisage sur un segment de type aviation
régional puisque le défi vous l'avez
souligné il est pas même si on fait
l'effort dans un premier temps pour
démontrer que la technologie avion la
plateforme pour être certifiable le défi
contrairement à la génération suivante
de type ultra frugal le défi va être au
niveau de l'écosystème global
c'est-à-dire qu'il s'agira pas non
seulement d'avoir un avion certifié
hydrogène mais évidemment d'avoir
l'hydrogène stockée au sol
approvisionner transporter donc c'est un
défi évidemment au niveau des compagnies
aériennes au niveau de la chaîne
logistique au niveau des aéroports on a
pu toute proportion gardée rencontrer
déjà des défis d'adaptation d'ensemble
de l'écosystème avec la 380 qui était un
appareil de génération différente
j'arrête là le parallèle on parle pas du
tout des mêmes défis mais malgré tout
c'est la cohérence globale du système
qu'il faudra adapter et donc là par
rapport au segment cœur qui est le
monocouloir qui est la 320 qui
représente en termes de volume là par le
plus important donc il s'agit pas
d'aller d'entrer avec la technologie
nouvelle sur ce segment-là mais d'y
aller plutôt progressivement et c'est
pour ça que c'est d'abord dans un
premier temps une aviation régionale qui
est visée avec des distances plus plus
réduites avant de passer à l'étape à
l'étape supplémentaire donc par rapport
à votre question ça va être une logique
progressive on travaille sur deux
technologies en parallèle on les
introduit sur des segments de marchés
différents et à un moment donné
évidemment nous les introduire sur le
même segment et en particulier
pour la décarbonation qu'elle segment
des monos des monocaux des monocouloirs
et donc une introduction
progressive donc où on en est on est
dans l'exécution finalement de cette
feuille de route coracle de ce master
plan ça a démarré avec le plan de
relance en 2020 France 2030 a pris a
pris la suite et on a une feuille de
route très claire avec des échéances de
démonstration sol et vols dans les
années qui viennent d'ici la fin de la
décennie donc j'en viens à votre
question par rapport finalement au
financement de cette feuille de cette
feuille de route on a jusqu'à présent à
travers un engagement très fort de
l'État dans le cadre du plan de relance
en 2020 il s'agit sain non seulement
évidemment de financer une feuille de
route technologique par rapport de
carbonation mais également de d'assurer
le maintien des compétences par rapport
à un secteur
directement touchée par la crise par la
crise covid donc le plan de relance a eu
le mérite non seulement de manière
compétence mais d'initiée toute cette
feuille de route technologique à travers
France 2030 finalement la continuité et
la dynamique c'est accélérer et donc
l'enjeu puisque évidemment il n'y a pas
d'effet falaises on parle de feuilles de
route technologiques et donc on parle
pas d'innovation qu'on doit démontrer
sur un horizona dans deux ans on est
plutôt sur 56 ans 7 ans l'enjeu à partir
de 2024 c'est d'être capable de donner
de la visibilité donc d'avoir les
financements budgétaires pour poursuivre
cette feuille de route conformément à
conformément master plan qui a été
défini donc le financement du coracle
n'est pas assuré oui au sens où le
budget à partir de 2024 2028 n'est
aujourd'hui pas totalement validé il y a
des discussions entre les différents
acteurs industriels le coracle et puis
des services étatique et l'objectif
c'est bien de donner de la visibilité
quand on est dans le domaine de
l'innovation de la R&D on est sur des
démonstrations sur plusieurs années donc
l'objectif c'est de viser c'est d'avoir
une une enveloppe budgétaire
pluriannuelle qui permette d'exécuter
cette feuille de route d'innovation qui
vise à valider les technologies qui
permettront de lancer les programmes qui
sont essentiels pour mettre en place et
viser et atteindre cet objectif de
décarbonation elles ont à l'horizon
2000-2050 donc on a on a une feuille de
route très claire qui inclut l'hydrogène
avec cette vision
échange échéancier de d'entrée en
service des différentes technologies une
validation budgétaire qui a été validée
dans le cadre de France 2030 pardon du
plan de relance en 2030 et donc l'enjeu
maintenant c'est de valider les budgets
sur la période à venir c'est essentiel
on est dans une période de
transformation telle que l'industrie
aéronautique ne l'a sans doute jamais
connu je mentionnais dans mon
introduction le fait qu'on fait face à
la quatrième révolution du secteur
aérien l'image à mon avis est bonne
c'est la réalité
donc l'ambition de chacun est forte
assurons-nous que les moyens sont mis en
face de cette ambition les acteurs
industriels l'ensemble des donneurs
d'ordre ils sont ils sont décidés sont
décidés à faire les investissements au
niveau au bon niveau de leur côté il est
essentiel évidemment que côté
gouvernement côté étatique qui est cette
poursuite de l'effort afin d'atteindre
les objectifs les objectifs visés
Béatrice Gosselin
le micro s'il te plaît
merci
oui vous parliez donc de l'acide de la
du lancement des programmes cette
feuille de route dont vous avez parlé
est-ce que est-ce qu'elle est commune
sachant que vous parliez de changement
de moteur ensuite les optimisation des
trajectoires des architectures des
avions pour optimiser et ensuite pour
arriver à des avions conception
différentes par exemple avec les jeunes
liquide est-ce que c'est trajectoires
sont semblables dans d'autres pays qui
ont ces filières aéronautiques à travers
le monde est-ce que est-ce qu'on a aussi
ces évolutions semblables ou c'est très
divergent et la deuxième question
parlait d'incidation fiscale qu'est-ce
qui peut se faire pour que vous ayez à
la fois maintenant que vous avez des
feuilles de route et que vous avez la
raison 2030 voire 2050 qu'est-ce qui
pourrait se mettre en place pour que les
R&D est la filière puisse arriver à ses
objectifs sans trop de difficultés et je
n'ai je vais mettre de côté parce que
c'était une troisième question sur les
comment vous imaginiez parce que vous
parliez tout à l'heure
d'approvisionnement d'hydrogène mais
c'est vrai que c'est aussi un souci
c'est que toute cette qui ne dépendra
pas vraiment uniquement de vous donc
voilà je vais m'arrêter à ces deux
questions
que je n'ai pas totalement répondu à la
question précédente où en êtes-vous de
l'hydrogène il y avait la partie où on
est de vous de l'électrique donc on
poursuit évidemment différents axes
technologiques au-delà de l'évolution
des technologies moteurs ou avion donc
l'hydrogène on la mentionné mais
également l'électrique c'est l'aspect
hybridation
complément complément de puissance
électrique ou technologie moteur en
particulier c'est c'est un axe
évidemment sur lequel sur lesquels on
travaille en particulier par rapport à
l'échéance avion ultra frugal il y a une
dimension hybridation électrique qui est
inclue dans la dans la feuille de route
c'est aussi un axe pour les plateformes
et véhicules de taille de taille plus
réduite le le l'enjeu d'hydrogène
évidemment sa densité énergétique est
très forte c'est une solution qui permet
de viser finalement la neutralité
carbone le défi de l'hydrogène c'est sa
densité volumétrique et donc si on peut
l'envisager sur des avions commerciaux
sur des PLA une forme plus réduite je
connais bien le sujet au niveau de
l'hélicoptère mais on peut l'imaginer
aussi sur des avions l'aviation générale
ou plus réduite c'est une technologie
qu'on voit moins directement applicable
donc l'aspect électrique ou hybridation
complément moteur électrique par rapport
à par rapport à la technologie de
propulsion classique fait bien partie de
la feuille de route j'avais pas adressé
ce volet de la question je tenais en le
swing par rapport à votre question
comment on voit la mobilisation des
autres des autres pays d'abord on voit
une mobilisation qui se fait
autour de ce sujet de la décarbonation
dont l'ensemble des pays on a pu penser
avec l'initiative dans le cadre du plan
de relance que quelque part on était les
premiers partis c'est vrai mais
justement et c'est l'effet positif
l'effet d'entraînement a bien eu lieu
alors au niveau européen et on voit à
travers les les efforts budgétaires en
Allemagne en Espagne en Angleterre que
l'ensemble des pays des pays se
mobilisent autour de cet enjeu des
carbonation sont bien
identifier le fait que cet enjeu de
qualité carbone passait par cette
transformation technologique et chaque
pays évidemment se mobilise pour
s'assurer que son sa chaîne industrielle
secteur industriel feront partie de la
génération de la génération suivante
donc c'est c'est aussi une question qui
nous est posée au niveau au niveau
national on est on a pris les mesures on
est engagé on a une vraie dynamique
gardons cette dynamique là pour rester
autour de la table parce que parce que
dans le même temps un certain nombre
d'acteurs au niveau européen
sont très mobilisés et font les forts
budgétaires on voit aussi au niveau des
États-Unis on voit aussi au niveau des
États-Unis on parlait du mécanisme irré
que finalement cet enjeu de la
décarbonation et clairement en haut de
en haut de l'agenda avec des mécanismes
évidemment réglementaires importants les
carburations les carburants d'aviation
durable sont vus comme un levier d'ordre
1 mais on voit que autour d'hydrogène il
y a aussi des programmes financés côté
statique par les différentes
gouvernementale donc c'est bien
l'ensemble des pistes technologiques qui
sont regardées je pense que le défi
c'est une ambition incroyable évidemment
d'être de faire partie de cette aventure
là neutralité Carbonat horizon 2050 mais
on voit que au regard de l'ambition on
ne peut pas négliger un seul des levier
et c'est bien l'ensemble des leviers
qu'il faut travailler c'est la
conclusion à laquelle on arrive au sein
du Cora qu'avec des acteurs éthiques
mais c'est aussi ce qu'on voit au niveau
international à travers la mobilisation
dans les différents pays européens au
niveau au niveau États-Unis
sur la chaîne vous avez moins
d'informations je pense que c'est plus
compliqué de savoir un petit peu
l'évolution aéronautique ah bon
excuse-moi
je pense que on a difficile mais où ils
seront ce qu'on voit d'abord on voit
bien leur ambition
de se positionner comme acteur majeur
dans dans le secteur aérien on a eu le
succès enfin le développement et
l'avancement du programme du programme
Comac et nul doute qui mettrons les
moyens donc c'est une question de une
question de temps on voit bien et
effectivement c'était le point qu'on
discute entre nous il se mobilise sur
l'hydrogène on voit donc derrière il y a
évidemment l'enjeu de la bicarbonation
c'est c'est finalement une nouvelle
génération et donc c'est l'occasion pour
eux de se repositionner sur la
génération suivante donc oui ils sont
ils sont fortement présents
oui merci j'ai regardé la question sur
la Chine effectivement qui est quand
même
à regarder de très près non votre
démonstration est très intéressant je
voudrais juste faire quelques remarques
vous dites bien que l'avion est
hydrogène ou la capacité plutôt un
intérêt régional or on a pris des
mesures pour que par rapport au train
des régions n'utilisent plus l'avion
parce qu'on ferme les liaisons entre
différentes capitales régionales dès
l'instant où elles sont en moins de deux
heures donc on peut se poser un peu des
des questions quand à cette stratégie là
quel est votre point de vue là-dessus
d'autre part vous êtes un des premiers à
nous parler enfin pas le premier puisque
on a eu on a eu une audition
intéressante sur le principe de
l'hydrogène par thermolyse par
pyrogazéification alors que alors que
jusqu'à présent on avait l'impression
que on imposait la technologie de
l'électrolyse par rapport à la
thermolyse or il nous semblait que ça
pouvait être intéressant puisque
ça consomme un peu plus de de biomasse
mais beaucoup moins d'électricité que
par rapport à l'électrolyse donc je
voulais savoir c'est le BTL si j'ai bien
noté donc ça intéresse ça confirme ce
qu'on avait entendu quand on a
auditionné certains
acteurs est-ce que mais vous avez
répondu peut-être indirectement on vous
impose pas une technologie on nous a
fait souvent la la remarque de l'Iran
vraiment Lyra ça ressort à toutes les
auditions en disant que les Américains
qu'est-ce qui se démerdent bien quand
même quand ils veulent quelque chose et
ils disent voilà on veut arriver à zéro
émission de CO2 démerder excusez-moi à
vous de trouver les technologies qui
vont permettre d'arriver à ça en France
on nous dit plutôt vous offrez de
l'électro et vous ferez de l'hydrogène
pour arriver à ça est-ce que vous sentez
qu'on vous impose une technologie ou
bien non vous apparemment dans votre
feuille de route il y a vraiment
plusieurs voix complémentaires très
intéressants mais quand on fait le point
comme ça plus d'autres auditions moi ce
matin j'ai été en audition avec le
groupe filière bois sur la bio sur
l'énergie bois et puis l'énergie
chauffage
on voit bien qu'ils vont avoir à
consommer également beaucoup beaucoup de
biomasse quoi donc il s'agira de
répartir un petit peu l'usage de tout ça
et je commence à avoir certaines
inquiétudes par rapport à cette
décarbonation qui est vraiment vraiment
la bonne voie mais compte tenu de la
répartition qu'il faudra trouver de la
biomasse et de l'électricité qui va
falloir produire en nombre
un nombre considérable c'est quoi les
quelques centrales nucléaires
supplémentaires ou les quelques
éoliennes ou autres qui vont suffire
donc on se pose vraiment la question
est-ce que derrière chacun va faire sa
feuille de route et il y aura-t-il un
plan un peu commun pour trouver les
usages non pas forcément en cascade mais
en débouché complémentaire
et est-ce que vous avez déjà des
négociations avec les filières
automobiles la filière énergie chauffage
et les autres filières qui se tournent
vers cette décarbonation bien entendu si
chaque collègue
par rapport à la feuille de route
hydrogène le point c'est pas de dire que
l'intérêt est dans le régional l'intérêt
il est dans l'ensemble des secteurs le
régional mais également l'aviation
commerciale également le mono couloir
donc l'idée c'est bien de viser
l'ensemble de ces segments là et donc y
compris demain un potentiel successeur
de la 301 qui représente le gros des le
gros des flottes que ce soit au niveau
national européen ou international c'est
plutôt une logique d'introduction
progressive avec un intérêt général ça
veut pas dire c'est exclusif sur
régional mais de marée progressivement
par un segment un segment de marché
avant d'avoir un déploiement à une
échelle plus plus importante donc le
commentaire sur le fait que pour être
envisagé un démarrage sur le régional ne
signifie pas que le marché visé est
nécessairement le régional on voit par
rapport à la l'objectif 2050 de
neutralité carbone c'est bien l'ensemble
des segments d'aviation commerciale
qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il faut viser
vous faites le parallèle avec vous
faites le parallèle avec le train
schoulinerai simplement que le segment
aérien c'est un marché qui est pas
uniquement national il est international
que les problématiques d'infrastructures
qui permettent de déploiement des
différents moyens de transport il est
pas forcément le même dans tous les dans
tous les pays donc de ce point de vue là
le secteur aérien c'est une solution
assez assez unique pour être capable de
répondre à des enjeux de décloisonnement
de connexion de transport dans toutes
les pays dans tous les pays du monde et
on se doit de raisonner à cette échelle
là même si évidemment on n'ignore pas
les problématiques les problématiques
nationales donc ça me semble essentiel
de l'avoir de l'avoir en tête et là
encore dès lors que une solution
décarbonée existerait j'imagine
j'imagine j'imagine que que cette
question du débat train avion ne se
poserait pas de la même de la même
manière j'espère que les décisions elles
sont elles sont fondées paramètres là de
la de la décarbonation je laisserai
Baptiste aborder le sujet BTL plus
technique des éléments de comparaison
oui mais alors rapidement effectivement
on voit pas
d'imposition d'un choix technologique
sur le sur la filière comme on a pu le
décrire sur les différents scénarios et
c'est pour ça justement qui a trois
grands scénarios dans notre feuille de
route avec un scénario action et puis
deux scénarios accélération ou justement
la variance entre les deux scénarios
c'est l'introduction des
électrocarburants par rapport au
biocarburant
et le
l'enjeu de pondération entre les
éléments là c'est un choix de
disponibilité de biomasse évidemment
avec cet enjeu de d'être sur une
biomasse non alimentaire donc
effectivement plutôt filière bois et
plutôt des résidus ligne cellulosique en
termes de constitution chimique plutôt
que d'autres d'autres approches
alimentaires donc
un équilibre entre effectivement et donc
un
choix sur cette approche de
disponibilité de la biomasse quelle
qu'elle soit et donc non alimentaires et
puis de la puissance installée puissance
électrique donc en fait on voit bien que
les différents choix et les différentes
aujourd'hui 7
cette différence voie de procéder de
production de ces de ces carburants
alternatif après la pondération va se
faire et c'est bien là qu'on parle d'une
filière et cette pondération elle va
venir dans le temps et elle va venir sur
des choix généraux et pour compléter ton
point nous impose aucun choix
technologique je voudrais insister
là-dessus c'est-à-dire que ce qu'on
partage non pas ce qu'on nous impose
mais ce qu'on nous ce qu'on partage chez
l'ambition 2050 d'un secteur aérien
décarboné on a une feuille de route
ambitieuse mais réaliste qui répond et
qui combine différents leviers et ça
c'est le résultat d'une analyse
objective rationnelle technologique qui
exactement qui inclut c'est que il faut
il faut l'ensemble des paramètres j'ai
souligné dans mon propos liminaire que
c'est levier là sont liés la technologie
qui vise à avoir un avion ultra frugal
c'est elle-même grâce à la réduction de
la consommation qui permettra le
déploiement des carburants d'aviation
durables puisque ils seront étant de
coups plus de production plus élevée
donc les deux sont paramètres donc
l'hydrogène il nous est pas imposé il y
a une conviction du fait que c'est une
solution technologique qu'il est
essentiel d'explorer pour avoir
l'ensemble des leviers qui permettent
d'avoir un secteur aérien décarbonés
d'où l'enjeu dans le cadre de la feuille
de route coracle dans les années qui
viennent d'être capable de
continuer à instruire ces choix ses
choix technologiques donc c'est
important d'avoir on nous impose rien
c'est bien c'est bien le résultat d'un
travail partagé au niveau des acteurs
industriels avec les secteurs éthiques
je crois que c'est aussi la force du du
Cora qui finalement combine l'ensemble
de l'ensemble des acteurs que ça soit
les grands donneurs d'ordre que ça soit
les PME que ça soit les ETI que ça soit
les les finalement les services
hépatiques compétents pour arriver à une
feuille de route ambitieuse mais mais
mais mais réaliste je pense que par
rapport au sujet de la biomasse
électricité s'est abordé je voudrais
simplement souligner qu'on a une
opportunité assez unique aussi en France
par rapport à cet enjeu de développement
de la filière carburant navigation
durable avec en particulier l'enjeu un
moment donné des des car burants
synthétiques qui supposent y compris
pour l'hydrogène d'avoir de
l'électricité des carbonée on a cette
capacité donc on a les ingrédients au
niveau national de développement d'une
filière d'une filière qui répondent aux
enjeux
oui là où vous avez plein de raisons
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la puissance
électrique installée n'est pas
suffisante une économie du carbonée si
on dépasse notre industrie aura besoin
de beaucoup beaucoup plus d'électricité
qu'aujourd'hui c'est clair l'hydrogène
fera le produit
et d'eau en même temps
et d'eau et en même temps
je vais essayer de pas de relancer mais
de faire préciser si vous voulez par
rapport
aux rapports qu'on va rendre ou on va
formuler un certain nombre de
propositions alors je partage
l'inquiétude ou le réalisme de mon
collègue Savary quand on fait des
auditions au bout d'un moment on se pose
et on rejoint tout compte fait une
remarque qui est faite par Jean-Marc
jankovinci quand il introduit son débat
en disant aujourd'hui il faut quantifier
nos besoins et quand on entend on peut
soit avoir des inquiétudes ou en tous
les cas regarder les choses avec
primatismes tout à l'heure
vous avez utilisé l'image de la poule et
de l'offre alors évidemment un instant T
de l'évolution on peut se poser la
question de dire pour avoir une poule
une fois un œuf et pour avoir un œuf il
me faut une poule sauf que c'est à
l'instant T d'une évolution
qui a mis un certain temps pour arriver
à proposer une reproduction par l'offre
au niveau des
oiseaux et si je dis ça c'est parce que
tout au long de cette évolution il y a
eu un parcours et on voit bien quand on
regarde ceux qui étudient l'évolution de
la nature que dans la nature il y a eu
des expériences des chemins on est
séchements étaient en bonne année pris
autrement vous venez de nous parler d'un
écosystème alors là c'est pas c'est nous
qui essayons de le monter à développer
d'ici 2050 dans un écosystème il y a
plusieurs acteurs et de votre point de
vue dans ces acteurs quels sont ceux qui
sont des des points renforcés je veux
pas dire des faiblesses mais des points
renforcés et par quels moyens on peut
les renforcer pour que l'écosystème
puisse avoir toute sa force d'ici 2050
le premier défi
il est technologique de ce point de vue
là les actions sont identifiées sont
lancées on est sur un temps qui est pas
un temps court il s'agit de démontrer
une faisabilité technologique avant de
lancer des programmes mais
les actions sont engagées
l'enjeu il est à travers votre question
ou des raisons plutôt sur s'assurer que
les conditions la partie budgétaire sont
là pour être capables d'exécuter la
feuille de route Corax sur l'horizon de
de la décennie et ne pas perdre de
bénéfice de ce qui a été engagé à
travers le plan de relance et France
2030 et je dirais qu'il y a le défi il
est là il faut le clarifier dans les
dans la période à venir mais les actions
sont sont engagées je pense que là il y
a un enjeu à accélérer
même si les actions s'engagées c'est sur
l'aspect écosystème et puis l'aspect
carburant navigation durable demain
hydrogène sur le fait que finalement
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'écosystème
sont présents alors pourquoi je dis
accélérer donc c'est à la fois il y a
une prise de conscience et un alignement
de l'ensemble des acteurs sur le fait
que c'est un besoin et d'où le groupe de
travail qui a été créé sous l'égide
ministérielle à partir de février avec
l'ensemble des acteurs pour moi c'est
une c'est une dynamique très positive
c'est la preuve qui est un alignement
une volonté d'y aller pour autant on
démarre de ce point de vue là par
rapport à la feuille de route
technologique qui a été engagée depuis
2020 pour de bonnes raisons puisqu'on
est sur le temps long on est on est on
est sur des initiatives beaucoup plus
récentes je dirais que c'est dans ce
domaine là la mobilisation les mesures
incitatives pour faire en sorte que
l'ensemble des acteurs a commencé par
des acteurs de la production
énergéticiens mais également les
utilisateurs pour qu'ils soient
finalement inc à pouvoir utiliser ces
nouveaux carburants et rentrer dans
cette dans cette spirale vertueuse c'est
à mon avis là que sont que sont les
défis les défis d'accélération puisque
la technologie qui souvent fait le temps
long pour le coup elle est disponible
moteur avion sont déjà certifiés à 50%
donc on a les ingrédients
il faut il faut mettre les l'écosystème
en branle je pense qu'il y a un bon
alignement
une prise de conscience et une volonté
il faut il faut maintenant traduire
concrètement 6 % en 2030 par rapport à
la corporation des carburants d'aviation
durables c'est peu et beaucoup c'est peu
par rapport à l'objectif qu'on a en 2050
c'est beaucoup par rapport
aux 0 % qu'on a aujourd'hui avec tout
l'enjeu de développement d'écosystèmes
de chaîne logistique de production et
donc c'est à mon sens là puisque c'est
le premier levier en termes d'horizon de
temps il est il est important de bien
s'assurer que la mobilisation continue
merci tout début de votre intervention
vous avez parlé de la situation
internationale des problèmes liés à
l'intention vous avez cité ressources
humaines est-ce qu'aujourd'hui dans ce
domaine-là vous avez toute la compétence
qu'il faut pour réussir cet écosystème
est-ce que vous avez les ressources
humaines nécessaires suffisantes voilà
c'est un point que j'aimerais que vous
faisiez part
le sujet pipi n'hésite pas à compléter
le sujet des Ressources Humaines je le
soulignais dans le contexte initial par
rapport à l'enjeu global de la filière
de de monter en cadence donc mon point
était pas spécifique par rapport à
l'enjeu de l'exécution de la feuille de
route techno technologique même si ça en
fait partie c'est vraiment par rapport à
quand on regarde la séquence que le
secteur vient de traverser c'est une
séquence unique une crise une crise de
la demande brutale avec la crise covid
en
2020 une disparition presque totale du
marché en l'espace de de quelques de
quelques semaines et puis finalement
tout aussi brutalement 2021-2022 une
reprise du trafic aérien avec la crise
dans laquelle on est finalement une
crise de l'offre une capacité de
l'ensemble du système industriel dont
les hommes et les femmes sont les
premiers maillons à monter en cadence
donc mon message il était il était
autour de cette montée en cadence
industrielle par rapport finalement
la technologie et au programme et au
programme d'aujourd'hui et donc de
souligner que cet enjeu de décarbonation
cet enjeu d'investissement majeur est
exécution d'une feuille de route de
décarbonation sur l'horizon 2020-20130
qui supposait l'investissement important
s'inscrit dans un contexte où le secteur
n'est pas totalement sorti de la crédit
il est plus dans la même crise mais il
reste dans un contexte difficile de
monter de monter en cadence donc après
il y a aussi des défis en termes de
compétences spécifiques par rapport en
termes d'innovation d'être génériques
par rapport à l'exécution de cette
feuille de route technologique mais mais
mais là mon ma remarque plus générale
serait de dire finalement en termes
d'attractivité cette cette perspective
d'innovation de nouveaux programmes de
technologie nouvelles au niveau des
ingénieurs et et technicien c'est
quelque chose qui qui a tendance à
attirer
on a la chance en France notre secteur a
la chance d'avoir des écoles
d'ingénieurs dédiées
et ça c'est très très important donc
c'était tout le groupe Isaï ils avaient
super haut avec le Staka ils avaient
l'école de Poitiers Lens
et ça c'est totalement différent en
Allemagne par exemple les meilleurs
ingénieurs
parmi les meilleurs ingénieurs la
plupart viennent chez nous c'est pas le
cas en Allemagne ils vont dans
l'automobile
est beaucoup moins porteur en Allemagne
nous non
on soutient assez massivement le gif
face le groupe ISAE super héros et les
NACs
et dernièrement le directeur général me
disait que il avait pas eu de niveau ni
en qualité ni en quantité
à l'entrée comme elle a sorti de l'école
donc c'est plutôt rassurant bon à côté
de ça on est comme les autres secteurs
industriels on peine à recruter alors
moins bien sûr Airbus s'affrontent à
l'aise Dassault que les PME
en 2022 on a recruté 18000 personnes
et cette année l'objectif c'est 25000
d'où ce qu'on a évoqué la campagne
d'attractivité aéro recrute avec les RH
de nos entreprises qui sont présents les
journées grand public au sein du Bourget
d'où également parce qu'on ce qui est un
peu en dessous du radar mais on est
présent en région pour dans pour
justement favoriser essayer de d'attirer
les jeunes et les moins jeunes
les talents d'autant un besoin pour
construire la zone de masse que je
disais au tout début donc
c'est un point d'attention majeur le
niveau de recrutement mais en qualité
nous avons nous continuons à avoir des
très très bons jeunes ingénieurs et qui
fabriqueront la nanomètre et c'est un
enjeu formidable pour eux parce que
pendant longtemps ça a été une
innovation incrémentale depuis les
années 80-90 là c'est fini là on est
parti sur la voie de la décarbonation et
là on y va à marche forcer quoi parce
qu'on sait qu'on a pas le choix
bien Béatrice
dans le cadre des mobilités on se rend
compte qu'on part sur plusieurs
modalités de d'énergie c'est à dire
certains vont fonctionner à l'hydrogène
d'autres hybrides d'autres électricité
etc est-ce que on peut imaginer dans le
quand nous aurons passé cette cape de
change de décarbonation à des modalités
différentes aussi dans l'aviation
c'est-à-dire certains avions seront
plutôt biocarburant resteront bien
carburant d'autres hydrogènes d'autres
peut-être électriques hybrides oui oui
on peut l'imaginer on peut l'imaginer
d'abord parce qu'en fonction des
segments de marché donc des plateformes
la solution sera différente je parlais
d'hydrogène par rapport à ça densité
volumétrique de fait entre l'aviation
commerciale et puis l'aviation générale
ou l'hélicoptère de fait des solutions
seront différentes et parce que à
l'image de ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on
reste quand même sur finalement une
introduction progressive des nouveaux
des nouvelles technologies on va rester
dans des concomitances finalement de
technologie donc c'est le défi de
l'écosystème de l'énergie que dire qu'il
y en aura pas une seule énergie capable
de pouvoir être
oui alors cela dit je pense que l'avenir
est à la mixité dans tous les domaines
il y a qu'à voir nos villes comme on les
évaluent en mode de déplacement et y
compris je pense pour nos propres
déplacements on utilisera différents
modes bien écoutez
monsieur Evens mesdames messieurs merci
beaucoup de nous avoir accordé de votre
temps de l'éclairage et nous allons
essayer de tirer profit de vos éléments
merci beaucoup
merci pour votre activation encore merci
beaucoup